et maintenant c'est l'heure de guillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est pas là il est plus là christian
estrosi ah ben non il est rentré à nice
à il avait un avion oui c'est vrai ils
ont souvent les avions les politiques
oui détecte arrive à mon avis ils sont
sur le tarmac pourtant moi je les aime
bien je m'en occupe chaque semaine je
m'y intéresser et e t'as vu c'est pas de
réciprocité faut pas que je m'attache
comme ça c'est trop sentimental on
commence par une bonne nouvelle la
france retrouve son rayonnement
international grâce à une poignée de
mains d'une virilité historique loin
devant celle de yasser arafat et itzhak
rabin mitterrand helmut kohl reagan
gorbatchev mao nixon le petit prince
dans marche à broyer la main de donald
trump
cette main qui attrapent les femmes par
la chatte ses phalanges boudinés au mac
do you kfc ses doigts qui se sont
introduits dans toutes les [ __ ] russe
fournis par vladimir poutine lebel
emmanuel les à concasser écrabouillé
éparpillé façon puzzle
[Applaudissements]
macron c'est le personnage du blond dans
le sketch de gad elmaleh quoi qu'ils
fassent ils restent impeccables toi
quand il ya du vent tes cheveux se
mettre n'importe comment quand il fait
froid at on est cool quand tu t'assois
ton costume se froisse macron non macron
serre la main de trunks 1 mètre 90 pour
90 kg sans sourciller sans transpirer
sans se mordre la langue même quand il
dort macron à la laine menthol et
[Applaudissements]
le blanc peut tout entreprendre tous
permettent recevoir poutine à versailles
en grande pompe tapis rouge garde
républicaine restaurants étoilés ça
passe son prédécesseur aurait fait la
même chose le petit gros avec sa
peinture noire et sa cravate de travers
ç'aurait été un tollé quoi poutine à
versailles cet assassin qu'a fait
trucider des dizaines d'opposants
politiques se mons qui a annexé
l'ukraine bombarder des civils on le
reçoit comme une star de cinéma mais là
là c'est le blond leblond tu lui
pardonne tout costume impeccable cravate
assortie à la baisse les divers de chez
guerlain tout le sens à travers ta télé
tu as vu ce qu'il a dit à poutine que
c'était le dernier avertissement que la
prochaine fois qu'il laissait une
population se faire gazer c'était
terminé la fanfare le trianon le
déjeuner chez ducasse terminé la france
ripostera la france tire à casser la
gueule à la russie leblond le plus on
tue ne fout pas de sa gueule deux fois
de suite
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron star de fiction érotique
sur internet ouais c'est fou c'est fou
le nombre de choses qui n'étaient pas
possibles soit hollande et qui le
deviennent supa crew
[Musique]
déclarations de jean christophe
cambadélis je ferai de la politique
jusque dans ma tombe [ __ ]
cambadélis qui pour le moment tient des
meetings debout juché sur une palette
rouge devant trois personnes
espérons qu'au cimetière il aura un tout
petit peu plus de monde
une fois n'est pas coutume dans cet
univers dur qu'est la politique une
pensée amicale à jean luc mélenchon
atteints du syndrome gilles de la
tourette une maladie neurologique
héréditaire 17 ans à l'école communale
de tanger le petit jean luc traiter ses
camarades de caca boudin de crottes de
nez de bébé cadum haut à l'époque on en
souriait en 91 la maladie s'aggrave jean
luc se fabrique le physique de landru
moustache et barbichette noire en 2008
rupture avec le ps les insultes de
bienne plus dur salle conviennent
crevard en mars 2010 cette brève période
de rémission jean luc et de nouveaux
souriant sympathique on le croit sauver
puis mercredi 24 mail c'est la rechute
total brutale jean-luc très bernard
cazeneuve de meurtrier
cazeneuve dit il le gars qui s'est
occupé de l'assassinât de rémy fraysse
le syndrome gilles de la tourette touche
un enfant sur mille à travers nous
non c'est triste un comme maladie c'est
pas ton que le malade n'occupe pas de
fonctions importantes ça va mais si mais
si
gagnes tu vois il est capable de
débarquer au stade vélodrome et dire
marseille on t'encule
enfin bref
[Applaudissements]
signalons que le dernier opus de harry
potter harry potter et les insoumis
est complètement nul quand c'est nul à
chier niel et par
le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb a dévoilé des éléments de
l'enquète sur l'attentât de manchester
que les policiers britanniques
souhaitaient garder sous silence bah oui
bah oui on a voulu supprimer les gens
malhonnêtes de la politique il reste que
les cons maintenant si on veut aussi
supprimer les cons y aura plus personne
[Applaudissements]
la sphère ferrand n'en finit pas de
faire des vagues faites ce que je dis
pas ce que je fais titre libération oui
enfin c'est quand même beaucoup moins
grave que la fir fillon ça n'a rien à
voir richard ferrand c'est un ami du
blond il est là depuis le début c'est
l'aspirateur dans marche merde on va
pâtir de la peine au blond mais on s'en
branle dès mutuel de bretagne qu'il ait
favorisé sa copine fait travailler son
fils et le confident du blond c'est son
ami d'enfance au poteau son copain ça
fait 40 ans qu'ils se connaissent il
faisait des concours de [ __ ] au lycée
on ne touche pas les amis du blow mer 2
[Applaudissements]
c'est difficile 1 qu'elle défende
je me donne un mal de chien
après sa mise en cause dans une affaire
d'emplois fictifs marielle de sarnez
reçoit un tweet de soutien de la part de
françois bayrou ministre de la justice
une initiative jugée inadaptée et
maladroite par le syndicat de la
magistrature
oui mais bon françois bayrou c'est grâce
à lui que le blond a gagné la
présidentielle
censé 5% leblond n'aurait jamais été élu
il serait retourné jouer au tennis au
touquet alors même si françois bayrou
est venu un prétentieux ya moitié dingue
c'est le copain du boulot leblond
leblond l'une soit on ne touche pas au
blond
[Applaudissements]
nouvelles révélations sur le financement
présumé de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy par le colonel kadhafi
un employé affecté à la communication de
l'ancien président affirme avoir reçu
une grande partie de son salaire en
espèces des liasses de billets de 10 20
et 50 euros entreposé dans une armoire
nicolas sarkozy a souhaité s'expliquer
sur ses pratiques
[Applaudissements]
écoutez
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
moraliser la vie publique que nos
concitoyens retrouvent confiance dans
leurs élus je voudrais dire une chose
que monsieur macron nous laisse le temps
de changer nos comportements
ce que vous croyez que c'est facile aux
républicains en quinze jours de déclarer
tout le monde
de supprimer nos emplois fictifs de
vider nos armoires de l'iki de se
débarrasser des valises comme nous
laisse le temps des rires dix ans
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai
fait une demande de carte bleue de
chéquiers
la banque n'aurait que la mesure qu'on
nous laisse le temps
je voudrais profiter de ce moment pour
remercier monsieur ferrand
quelle grâce à son comportement renoue
avec les traditions de la politique à la
papa le temps jadis je suis sûr que
monsieur pasqua
et monsieur de fer sont très émus de ce
magnifique hommage qui l'aurait rendu
vive la françafrique vive la république
et vive monsieur ferrand
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est lui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu